let's take a look at food we have on the
table no your eyes aren't deceiving you
that's Harry Styles and Kendall Jenner
dining together on TV well sort of
let's rewind on Tuesday the two who have
never officially confirmed their past
rumored romance sat down for a game of
spill your guts on The Late Late Show
where Harry was filling in for host
James Corden dying to know this which
songs on your last album were about me
yeah she went there
[Applause]
so I'd say track Harry and Kendall were
rumoured to be dating in 2016 at the
time a source close to Kendall told ET
that she was the first one to make a
move in st. Barths on New Year's Eve do
I think they're dating yes
yeah and then there was that Kendall's
older sis Khloe Kardashian spilling all
the hairy Kendall tea to et I don't know
if there was boyfriend/girlfriend I
don't know people are weird with stuff
so I I don't know their title but I mean
they were in st. Barths together hanging
out so to me that's dating I would call
that dating but back to spill your guts
mystery Lily Liam Niall and Zayn break
their soul Oh Harry played it safe
opting to eat a giant water scorpion
instead of ranking his former One
Direction band mates solo music but
Kendall didn't shy away from ranking her
famous siblings from best to worst
parents I'd say Rob is number one okay
and then I'm sure that's so hard they're
all amazing drink the eggnog no no and
then it would be like Savage oh and
guess who's a fan of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians have you ever watched an
episode of cute yeah it was the one
where you're eating salads in the
kitchen and then you all shouting each
other
turns out Kendall was a 1d fan - Kendall
we've been friends for a while and I've
heard that when we first met you're a
fan of One Direction but but what
exactly is happening in this boat in
this photograph
[Applause]
what's going on now did you make that
yourself
later in the episode Harry and guests
Tracee Ellis Ross called Kendall out for
her throwback homemade 1d poster tell us
the story wonderful ask me to do this
photo
you guys are Charpy or whatever chop it
yeah and I said sure and I wasn't
necessarily too aware at the time and
then I became aware after meeting you
and became a real fan well I like about
photography is that lips forever
[Music]